i regret to inform you that tucker
carlson has said something incredibly
stupid about the legal profession so it
might be time for joe biden to let us
know what kantaji brown jackson's lsat
score was what how did you do in the
lsat why wouldn't he tell us that yes
tucker carlson wants to see judge
katanji brown jackson's lsat score
here's the thing once you get into law
school no one will ever ask for your
lsat score again the lsat score has
nothing to do with the practice of law
lots of really great lawyers and judges
got really terrible lsat scores and vice
versa now whether you think judge
jackson would be good on the supreme
court or not is political and supreme
court nominees always are but looking at
the facts it's basically impossible to
claim that she's not at least qualified
she went to harvard law she served as an
editor on the harvard law review she
clerked for three judges at all federal
levels including on the supreme court
and judge jackson has almost nine years
of prior judicial experience which is
more than four current justices thomas
roberts kagan and barrett combined so
contrary to tucker carlson looking at
judge jackson's lsat score has
absolutely nothing to do with whether
she'd be a good supreme court justice